[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous amener emmenés dans les
années 30 de jeunes religieuses
américaines furent invités à écrire leur
biographie leur enfance leur scolarité
leur vocation leur entrée leur vie dans
les ordres
soixante ans plus tard trois chercheurs
de l'université du kentucky ont extirpé
leur oubli ses biographies dans le cadre
d'une enquête qu'il conduisait sur la
longévité ils les ont lus ils ont
recensé le nombre d'émotions positives
fierté plaisir joie qu'exprimaient les
unes et les autres
et ils ont mis en évidence que celle qui
en avait exprimé le plus avait en
moyenne vécu s'étendent plus que les
autres
de nombreuses recherches ont confirmé
cette corrélation entre nos émotions
positives le quota d'émotions positives
que l'on ressent dans notre vie et notre
santé notre espérance de vie
al'inverse d'autres études ont mis en
exergue que nos émotions négatives
lorsqu'elles sont enkystée chronique
impacte négativement notre espérance de
vie à titre d'exemple stress chronique
va augmenter de 20% notre risque de
décès prématurés les tempérament
colérique
sont aussi exposées une mort précoce que
les personnes qui fument qui souffre
d'hypertension artérielle ou qui
souffrent d'obésité
moi même je suis issu d'une famille qui
comptait une bonne tripotée d'hyper
sensible très peu équipés pour gérer nos
émotions dit négative on avait tendance
à bouder camp était contrarié au lieu
d'exprimer nos contrariété on avait
tendance à mettre un couvercle sur nos
chagrins lieu de les partager
dans l'hyper contrôle quand on était
stressés
ce qui fait que lorsque j'ai découvert
qu'il existait une grammaire émotionnel
une manière de comprendre gérer nos
émotions qui va impacter notre santé nos
relations aux autres notre vie
professionnelle ça a été une révélation
et j'ai été affligée que l'école ne nous
transmettent pas plutôt ses clés ses
connaissances c'est ce qui m'a amené à
reprendre cinq ans d'études en
psychologie pour transmettre en
attendant que l'école s'intéressent à ce
sujet
alors revenons à nos émotions positives
si elles ont un impact sur notre survie
pourquoi les lois de l'évolution ne nous
ont pas conduit à tous de venir de
joyeux lurons
on en est loin
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
identifié que la dépression était la
première cause d'incapacité dans le
monde aujourd'hui
20% des français francs une dépression
au cours de leur vie et un français sur
cinq souffrira de troubles anxieux au
cours de l'année à venir
et bien la faute en revient à un
mécanisme psychique que l'on appelle le
biais de négativité
ce mécanisme fait que notre faisceau
attentionnel est davantage attiré
impact et mémorise davantage les
événements négatifs que les événements
positifs de notre vie de nous-mêmes
d'autrui on pourrait se demander
pourquoi est-ce que ce mécanisme
n'existe à quoi il sert bien pour nos
ancêtres dans le paléolithique qui ont
vécu dans les environnements extrêmement
périlleux
lorsque l'un d'entre eux entendrait un
bruissement des offres dans un buisson
et prenait ses jambes à son cou
imaginant le pire
il permet peut-être quelques calories
dans l'histoire si en fait il ne
s'agissait que du vent qui soufflait
dans le buisson mais assurément il
sauver sa peau s'il s'agissait d'un
prédateur donc nous sommes les
descendants les plus pessimistes les
plus anxieux de nos ancêtres
ce mécanisme qui favorisait la survie
autrefois a tendance à nous gâcher la
vie aujourd'hui c'est ce biais de
négativité qui fait que s'il m'arrive 9
choses assez sympa dans la journée un
accroc c'est à cet accroc que je vais
réfléchir le soir en m'endormant
c'est ce qui fait que je vais me
souvenir d'un d'une critique que m'a
fait un proche ou un collègue il ya deux
ans en ayant oublié depuis tous les
compliments qu'ils ont pu me faire
c'est ce biais de négativité qui va
peut-être m'empêcher de changer de job
de changer de métier parce que ce
faisceau attentionnel voit tous les
risques mais difficultés que présente ce
changement en négligeant tous les
bénéfices qu'ils peuvent être à la clé
alors bonne nouvelle
notre cerveau et plastiques il se
remodèle se rééduque en fonction de
notre environnement en fonction de nos
pratiques de nos comportements attitudes
règle à titre d'exemple on s'est rendu
compte les chercheurs se sont rendu
compte que la zone qui gère
l'orientation spatiale des chauffeurs de
taxi londonien est bien plus développée
que celle des autres quidams eh bien
c'est ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
des pistes des pratiques pour rééduquer
votre faisceau attentionnel pour être
davantage attentif à ce qu'il y à
positif dans vos vies en vous même chez
autrui
commençons par ce qu'il ya de positif
dans nos vies je vais m'appuyer sur les
recherches de martin seligman qui est le
père de la psychologie positive un
chercheur américain
il y a plusieurs décennies déjà a
conduit une étude
il a demandé à de nombreux volontaires
qui l'a divisé en deux groupes
à ceux du premier groupe décrire tous
les soirs comme dans un journal intime
sur le sujet de leur choix
et aux volontaires du deuxième groupe il
a donné une consigne
écrivait tous les soirs dans votre
journal intime mais sur les trois
meilleurs moments de votre journée ce
qui les oblige évidemment à repenser à
leur journée et a rédigé à la revivre en
réécrivant cet événement positif
à la fin de l'étude qui duraient
plusieurs semaines martin seligman s'est
rendu compte que les participants du
deuxième groupe avait une humeur qu'ils
étaient bien meilleurs que ceux du
premier groupe
plus intéressant encore il a recontacté
tout ce petit monde plusieurs mois après
la fin de l'étude et les participants du
deuxième groupe continue à avoir un
niveau de bien-être supérieurs à ceux du
premier groupe donc voilà une première
pratique à explorer si elle vous tente
écrire chaque jour sur les meilleurs
moments de notre journée ce qui va
rééduquer notre fessio attentionnel pour
être attentif aux petits bonheurs de
notre vie
deuxième piste
sourire
je vais vous inviter à faire une
expérience avec moi pendant une minute
je vais vous inviter à sourire
et je vous invite à regarder votre
voisin de droite ou de gauche pour
vendre vous rendre compte que même
masquer un sourire se voit
je vais vous inviter à garder le sourire
pendant une minute je vous donne
quelques informations sur ce qui se
passe dans notre organisme alors que
vous êtes en train de sourire
la proverbe chinois qui disait sourire
trois fois par jour rend inutile tout
médicament c'est le cas pendant que vous
êtes en train de sourire garder le
sourire
votre taux de cortisol l'hormone du
stress est en train de baisser
vos endorphines qui produisent du
plaisir du bien-être elles sont en train
de monter votre système immunitaire est
en train d'être stimulés et cerise sur
le gâteau vous êtes en train d'activer
17 muscles et quand on active nos
zygomatiques
ça produit un effet hypertenseur ce qui
veut dire que les plus souriants d'entre
nous garderons plus longtemps une peau
de bébé
alors
je vous invite maintenant à détendre vos
zygomatiques
et à vous demander comment vous sentez
peut-être que vous vous sentez
légèrement plus joyeux qu'il y ait 60
secondes la magie de l'histoire c'est
que même un sourire complètement factice
fait le même effet c'est le fait d'
activer nos muscles qui produit toutes
ces réactions physiologiques donc je
vous invite la prochaine fois que vous
aurez le moral dans les baskets à
prendre un stylo avoue le coincé entre
les dents
à vaquer à vos occupations pendant une
vingtaine de minutes ou même dit si vous
n'en avez que 10 et je vous fais un bon
de garantie sur le fait que vous
sentiriez vous sentirez mieux après
qu'avant l'expérience voilà deux pistes
écrire son nom meilleurs petits moments
de la journée sourire à la vie deuxième
volet que je vous propose
rééduquer notre cerveau pour qu'ils
soient attentifs à tout ce qui est bon
tout ce qui va bien en nous
je vais m'appuyer ici sur les recherches
de christine nef qui travaille depuis
des années sur l'auto bienveillance
elle a mis en évidence que les personnes
qui sont bienveillantes avec elle-même
compréhensive soutenant tu ont davantage
confiance en elles
sont plus résiliente dans les
difficultés baisse moins vite les bras
progresse davantage
à ceux d'entre nous qui aurait un
critique intérieur très virulent qui
sont très exigeants avec eux mêmes
perfectionniste je vous invite à prendre
conscience de toutes les situations où
vous êtes en train de vous dénigrez doux
flageller pour
essayer de vous parler comme vous
parleriez à votre meilleur ami
imaginons que j'ai été désagréable avec
une collègue je m'en veuille je suis en
train de me flageller en faisant bien
vraiment je m'améliore pas avec les
années j'ai dû passer pour une
hystérique
et là je prends conscience que je suis
en train de malmener
halte-là vade retro esprit critique
que dirais-je à ma meilleure amie la
mienne s'appelle marie imaginons qu'il
lui soit arrivé là même bévue qu'elle me
raconte qu'elle a été particulièrement
agressive avec une collègue je lui dirai
sans doute pas que ce qui s'est passé
quel était le contexte qu'est
l'historique de vos relations
est ce que tu peux réparer est ce que tu
dois aller t'excuser
quels enseignements tian tir pour
l'avenir et bien si c'est le discours le
plus évident que j'ai à servir à ma
meilleure amie
aucune raison pour que ça ne soit pas
aussi le disco le plus évident pour moi
même
donc quand on est très exigeant avec
soi-même très critique prenant
l'habitude de nous traiter comme on
traiterait notre meilleur ami au lieu de
se traiter comme on ne traiterait pas
parfois notre pire ennemi
[Musique]
deuxième chose qui peut aussi cultiver
notre bienveillance à notre égard
arrêter les comparaisons inutiles
ont certainement tous surpris un jour en
train d'admirer quelqu'un et du coup de
se sentir tout petit pas à la hauteur et
de se dénigrer
pas très aidant
ce que je vous propose d'expérimenter la
prochaine fois que vous vous direz mais
mais ce collègue quelle force de
persuasion c'est incroyable ou cette
femme malade il a une carrière
époustouflante
au lieu de se comparer se sentir tout
petit
se demandait comment on peut apprendre
d'eux comment ils peuvent nous inspirer
remplacer les comparaisons inutiles par
des modélisations utile tiens ce
collègue là qui est si convaincant
comment il s'y prend ah oui je vois que
ça fait deux fois il commence sa
présentation en coupant l'herbe sous le
pied aux contradicteurs en leur disant
vous dit peut-être que ce que je propose
ne marchera jamais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi tiens c'est
particulièrement intéressant je vais
tenter ça la prochaine fois
où cette femme qui a une carrière
incroyable
je vais le lui demander si elle
accepterait qu'on déjeune ensemble pour
qu'elle me raconte son parcours pour lui
demander des conseils voire même
peut-être pour lui demander si elle
accepterait d'être mon mentor
voilà pour ce volet cultiver l'auto
bienveillance
en se traitant comme on traiterait son
ou sa meilleure amie en remplaçant les
comparaisons inutiles par des sources de
d'inspiration et de molly modélisation
enrichissante
troisième et dernier volet comment
cultiver notre attention pour qu'elle
voit tout ce que les autres font bien
ces gamins dans mélodie en sous-sol qui
disait
l'essentiel cédera les saf et bonjour
les études le montrent le confirme 41%
des français pensent qu'il passerait
pour des imbéciles et et aimable
alors pour paraphraser audiard
je pense qu'on pourrait dire qu'en
france si les esprits critiques volet il
frais nuit
alors si on vit ici on est entouré par
des gens qui ont fait un fonds de
commerce du fait de critiquer autrui on
a vu que ça faisait genre new deal gabin
il est important de prendre conscience
que les émotions sont contagieuses nous
avons dans le cerveau des neurones
miroirs qui font que quand j'interroge i
avec quelqu'un je ressens ce qu'il
ressent ces neurones miroirs ont
favorisé l'empathie donc la cohésion de
groupe donc la survie de l'espèce
et du coup quand je je suis en contact
quand j'évolue quand je vis avec des
gens très critique il me contamine d'une
certaine manière ça vaudrait peut-être
le coup soit de prendre des distances de
sécurité avec eux s'ils ne sont pas
importants pour nous soin d'essayer la
dé convaincre qu'ils sont en train de
flinguer sept ans d'espérance de leur
vie est peut-être un peu aussi de leur
attractivité parce que vraiment qu'on
soit en forme pour venir prendre un café
avec eux vu qu'on repart avec le moral
dans les baskets
distances de sécurité et puis soi même
devenir des êtres
gratifiant valorisons qui ont à coeur de
souligner ce que les autres font de bien
alors il ya des études aussi qu'ils ont
été très intéressantes sur ce sujet
notamment celle de john gottman qui est
un des plus grands chercheurs sur les
relations de couple qui il y a quelques
années en arrière de nombreuses années
en arrière s'est demandé s'il pouvait en
observant un couple fonctionné pendant
quelques heures
d'hier avec quasi certitude si ces deux
conjoints serait encore ensemble dans
dix ans et surtout heureux de l'être
donc il a filmé à dix couples il les a
recontacté dix ans après alors heureux
et là des rushes et les bandes vidéo
pour voir qu'est ce qu'ils ont en commun
c'est heureux conjoint est bien le
critère déterminant à la auquel il est
arrivé c'est le ratio entre le nombre de
critiques reprochent et le nombre de
compliments félicitations encouragements
partagé entre les deux membres du couple
alors je faire un petit sondage je vais
vous inviter à voter avec vos mains
selon vous les couples qui durent pour
une critique un reproche
combien de félicitations de compliments
allez-y c'est à vous 5 à ma gauche 4 à
ma droite 4 4 3 3 3 ma gauche qui dit
mieux disent
merci beaucoup
bravo à ceux qui ont voté pour 5 le
ratio des couples qui durent pour une
critique ce un compliment alors ceux qui
ont répondu disent déjà un pour cinq
c'est du boulot si vous rentrez ce soir
que votre chéri à préparer les pattes et
que vous lui dit ah ouh là trop salée
concrètement vous en prenez pour 5
compliments félicitations avant la wii
ça rigole plus avant de pouvoir à
nouveau émettre la moindre critique
des études dans le domaine de la vie
professionnelle ont également montré que
ce ratio entre feedback négatif et
feedback positif est un facteur clé de
performance des équipes les plus
performantes étant celle où il ya pour
une critique
3 feedback positif c'est moins sévère
parce qu'à moins d'un fact d'affect il
fait appeler une critique un axe
d'amélioration
changera rien aux quotas de 1 pour 3
alors
cerise sur le gâteau pour ceux qui sont
très gratifiant
non seulement on fait du bien aux autres
mais en plus on se fait du bien à soi
même
quand vous faites un compliment comme
quand vous offrez un cadeau à quelqu'un
vous avez une décharge de dopamine dans
le cerveau l'hormone qui va générer le
plaisir et bien cette décharge elle est
plus forte quand vous faites un
compliment quand vous faites un cadeau
que lorsque vous recevez un compliment
ou un cadeau c'est le double effet kiss
cool de la reconnaissance on fait du
bien aux autres on se fait du bien à soi
même
voilà donc pour conclure
cultiver nos émotions positives
c'est du plaisir en plus
ces sept ans d'espérance de vie en plus
c'est des rides en moins
autrement dit nos émotions positives
sont un véritable bain de jouvence
je vous invite à faire passer le mot
autour de vous notamment si vous avez
des contacts au ministère de l'éducation
nationale
parce que si le buzz fonctionne nos
émotions positives pourraient devenir le
meilleur concurrent de l'industrie du
botox
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]